ça chauffe de nouveau dans les coulisses
de danse avec les stars
à en croire les révélations du magazine
voici le retour exceptionnel d'iris
mythe narre dans le dernier prime de
l'émission n'aurait pas du tout été du
goût de sa coanimatrice karine ferri
alors que l'ancienne miss france
retrouvé le parquet de dallas aux côtés
d'anthony colette son ex danseur et ex
petit ami et d'alsace nous la nouvelle
partenaire de danse du jeune homme
en coulisses la colère de karine ferri
s'est fait entendre si le tango à troyes
s'est terminée par un baiser torride
entre elsa et iris qui a beaucoup fait
parler
pour karine ancienne miss ne serait
qu'une petite maline prête à tout pour
faire le buzz la coanimatrice aurait
même menacé tf1 et la production de
l'émission d'annuler sa présence un
chantage qui n'a pas eu d'effet une
guerre qui n'est pas nouvelle
puisqu'elle aurait débuté il ya quelques
temps alors qu'ils risquent prenait de
plus en plus de place sur la chaîne
en effet depuis de nombreux mois la
jeune femme a décoché la présentation du
loto de l'euro millions est la co
présentation de ninja warriors des
postes qui aurait pu revenir à karine
ferri qui se retrouvent donc en
concurrence avec cette miss très
populaire qui plaît beaucoup aux
dirigeants de tf1 face à la polémique
karine ferri a décidé de démentir les
rumeurs sur son compte instagram
vous avez tellement d'imagination une
défense qui ne convainc pas tout le
monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est dans le sable dans un imbroglio
pas faux financiers oui alors des infos
peut-être de monsieur people pas des
infos une opinion c'est encore mieux
après les lui qui n'a pas compris qui
rythment et nar je sors avec kev adams a
jeté le doute au fait l'euromillions
arrêtez-vous cette fiction à la
démission j'ai patiné changer celui qui
n'a pas compris qu'elle aimait la
lumière bay alors tout le monde allait
alors pardon je veux dire quelque chose
la célébrité d'une conséquence n'est pas
un objectif
donc il devrait d'abord distant un
délice à ces de l'ordre j'adore ce
qu'elle veut faire des choix this que tu
veux faire et puis après peut être que
la célébrité arrivera elle tout ce
qu'elle veut c'est la lumière allumée
avec quelques tweets et leurs vidéos de
playback
c'est pas comme ça que ça marche ça
alors je sais pas tout à fait d'accord
avec vous mathieu à mes hôtes elle sait
pas comment la femis france après elle
s'installe nous qui permet cette voie là
qu'est ce qu'elle veut faire
excusez moi les autres miss france l on
fait quoi vendait à l'antenne la
pardonnez pas beaucoup qui sort en
salles le 21 la plainte au phénomène
marine bras mais à sonia rolland c'est
devenu une comédienne excellente
oui alors je compte faire a pris des
cours de comédie tout ça alors elle
qu'est ce qu'elle fait avec la butte où
il fait le robinet aux échappées midi
musical ou par ailleurs c'était gênant
alors je vais vous dire la vérité même
quand vous êtes devenu méchant loup
illégal est devenu méchant et je les
grilles et l'appui aux troupes à défaut
s'il vous plaît je vous l'aï dit je vous
le redis la célébrité est une
conséquence et non objectifs et par
l'epa qui a réveillé d'un gain non se
mettre dans la lumière est l'annoncé par
la lumière fonde sur les podiums sont
contre cette phrase est il dû attendre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
des agapes agathe oui non mais pour ne
pas les faire passer pour deux mégères
s'est pas encore une guerre ouverte donc
ya pas de message y'a pas d' insulte ya
pas de sms est rien c'est une guerre
froide parce que c'est vrai que karine
avant l'arrivée des risques en a
beaucoup parlé sur ce plateau creafin la
reléguer un peu à des seconds rôles
toujours bonne des rôles à un peu bâtard
voir cette édition et elle a vu ses
vrais l'arrivée des risques d'un mauvais
oeil pascal de chômage ont plus ou moins
le même physique mais elles ont
exactement le même emploi on peut les
mettre exactement mais non quand
isabelle a vu l'arrivée 2 exactement
c'est trop nous ce n'est pas ta valise
tu vois pas la saq est vrai ou faux
[Applaudissements]
et pour gagner elle est passée au
vendredi qu'elle a quitté la semaine
elle m'a dit je l' ai bien eus mais j'ai
la semaine est celle vendredi tu dis la
vérité une amie j'ai jamais vu un mec
mentir mais kahn a prononcé
merci mme annie mercier aura des infos
sur faut bien quelqu'un qui travaille
ici bien caution des rues jean michel
may toujours voilà donc suite à
l'élimination clara morgane ce samedi
j'ai eu quelqu'un la production de tf1
qui m'a dit que c'était le feu nucléaire
a tf1 à cause de dalles ce bras pour
trois raisons principales
1le juin les y doucement raison
principale le jury il est bien et je
reviens souvent vert de rage parce
qu'ils seront rapidement décrédibiliser
il dit que c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire du format danse avec les
stars que quelqu'un qui est promis à dix
minutes de la fin
éjecté dix minutes plus tard jamais
arrivé de récession à marrakech avait
produit dernier dix minutes après que
jamais hanté jamais dans aucun pays
deuxièmement les dents les danseurs sont
en stress total parce que la production
l'armée à une pression de ouf à toutes
les spurs en vo dans ce mot corée sont
pas assez ambitieuses passer devant ce
pratiques passées pu passer entre
guillemets et c'est toujours la même
chose ça ronronne donc les danseurs
c'est la guerre entre eux et
troisièmement à la localiser doucement
et artois ces machos c'est tf1 qui
évidemment catastrophe parce que les
chiffres les audiences en chute libre et
surtout les appels téléphoniques qui
font gagner la champions
pratiquement diminué de moitié non donc
c'est ainsi une catastrophe totale donc
ils sont contraints de chercher de il ya
plus de stars qui vont bien faire bien
des missions reste-t-il
il reste 400 il reste il reste quatre
émissions mais les 25 scolaires de la
toussaint ça toujours baissés non non
non non là ces jeunes et pourquoi tf1
ils sont enrichis d'un scoop pour trois
raisons 1
ses danseurs non mais bravo jean michel
[Applaudissements]
alors et après l'émission il paraît que
après des missions de d'al silya vérisme
tonnerre et paraître karine elle était
très très énervé à l'accusé risque
d'être une petite maline prête à tout
pour faire le buzz et en cause en fait
c'est le baiser qu'elle a échangés avec
elsa est ce nous elle n'a pas digéré du
tout le baiser entre les deux ça lui est
resté en travers de la normal que ce
soit elle peut être non non moi alors
moi je vais vous dire jamais dans une de
mes émissions de moftah
[Musique]
son sein
sous mon sens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]